sometimes i believe that the images that  i have created  are nothing sensational nothing  futuristic or avant-gardistic  it is something that is deeply inside of  us dormant inside of us and i'm the one  who can awaken these images  and it's your images actually and it's  like  a brother or a sister unknown  unbeknownst to you who all of a sudden  comes to life  and you realize you've got a brother and  and this is wonderful if i can create  that and  and all of a sudden all of a sudden in  rare moments it happens when you hear  great music or when you see a great  movie  very rarely it happens that that you  have  moments of of deep illumination in  moments  where where you know that you are not  alone anymore  and that's the ultimate i can reach if  there's anyone out there who  who after seeing let's say strashek  has a feeling i'm not alone anymore then  i've  achieved everything i wanted to achieve  in my life